[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour accueillir le président un retour
sur le terrain chahuté comme il s'y
attendait c'est pas les casseroles qui
feront avancer la France on peut
relancer massivement l'industrie de
casserole aussi qui s'est produit pas
assez mais moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
ce qui va permettre à nos compatriotes
de mieux vivre
il y a des actions on va lui pourrir la
vie mais lui pourrir la vie et
manifestants sont présents équipés
notamment de casserole avec un important
dispositif de sécurité des manifestants
notamment de la CGT ou encore de la CFDT
il nous offrouillés pris les noms carte
d'identité enregistrée maintenant il
nous laisse pas rentrer interdiction de
du roi se parquer pour quelqu'un qui
aime les bains de foule il est pas très
courageux fêté en déplacement hier
justement à Strasbourg j'étais vendredi
dans le Val-d'Oise beaucoup de mes
collègues font la même chose il faut
faire attention mais il s'agit pas de
rester dans un cocon il s'agit pas de
rester enfermé et il s'agit pas de
refuser le contact parfois il y a des
risques mais on le fait parce que c'est
évidemment nécessaire
chacun d'entre nous à vocation aller sur
le terrain le président de la République
est à l'évidence le meilleur ambassadeur
de la politique conduite dans ce pays
depuis 6 ans il sera donc amené lui
aussi à se déplacer aujourd'hui en
Alsace demain ce sera sur la question de
l'école
des gens qui sont pas contents je vais
pas ne pas aller au contact parce que
les gens pas contents il faut que
tout manuel Macron est d'ailleurs sa
dernière allocution nous l'a montré à un
seul un seul type de discours qui
consiste à dire j'ai raison vous
comprenez pas mais j'ai raison et je
m'en fais et je me fiche du fait que
vous ne compreniez pas
que Cyril la main un président qui a
gouvernement aussi corrompu alors je me
suis dit faut pas louper ça
[Musique]
va être gentil c'est la réalité c'est la
réalité vous nourrissez
bonjour
vous allez tomber vous allez tomber ils
me disent tiens est-ce que vous diriez
que vous chanteriez avec nous là c'est
simple vous leur dites NON NON etc les
mêmes qui filment vous m'auriez fait 48
heures sur le thème il aimait présente
il est pas sympa crise démocratique
c'est du mépris et ma première réaction
c'est de me dire tant d'intelligence
pourtant d'incohérence c'est à dire
c'est un grand mystère Emmanuel Macron
qui n'est pas près d'être dissipé
néanmoins cette colère s'exprime je
m'attendais pas à autre chose mais elle
ne m'empêchera pas de continuer à me
déplacer partout à travers le pays parce
que nous devons continuer d'agir et
d'avancer Laurent Berger crée la
surprise le secrétaire général de la
CFDT l'a annoncé il quitte la tête de
son syndicat
il faut que les militants comprennent
une chose on est de passage et il vaut
mieux transmettre le témoin quand on est
bien lancé il devrait a priori laisser
sa place à l'actuel numéro 2 elle
s'appelle Marylise Léon c'est quelqu'un
pour qui j'ai dû respect aurais-je dire
de l'amitié avec qui j'ai toujours eu
des discussions d'ailleurs bien au-delà
de son de ces simples fonctions de son
mandat sur aussi la vie
il reste de la société qui a joué un
rôle qui joue encore un rôle important
dans un grand syndicat français ça
aurait été appartenaire sérieux exigeant
parfois coriaces nous l'avons vu et avec
lequel nous avons pu obtenir des
avancées importantes pour notre pays en
matière de droits sociaux lâché par un
radar mais sans perdre de points dans
quelques mois ce devrait être possible
le ministère de l'Intérieur vient de
l'annoncer dans une lettre les petits
excès de vitesse de moins de 5 km heure
ne serait plus sanctionné d'un retrait
de points oh mon dieu
ça s'est effondré ce parking de
plusieurs étages c'est affaissé sur
lui-même en quelques secondes